[Music]
uh hello
i was like what everyone whips their
neck and it's
elon doing a he's like doing you know i
hear a lot about stand-up comedy and i
find that
comedy is really about being honest yeah
grimes was actually sucking my dick last
night
do do you guys think that oh sorry i'll
let you finish
i thought that was the joke i mean or
was there i was trying to think of what
a joke like a joke elon would have made
that's what i'm saying what did elon
have like elon was at the end of the
joke for elon i feel like he'd just go
you know on twitter that people think
when grimes
sucks my dick she goes
but she doesn't she sucks it like a
regular person
i'm laughing
is she a robot i don't know man
i think people think she's like an alien
or something
that's the best on the fly elon you know
in character that's the best thing i
could come up with
i'm sorry i'm sorry that was so bad
you know if she wasn't good at uh
sucking dick um she'd potentially become
my
space x
there it is now what if it's just what
if it
it's not jokes at all it's just him
just talking about wildly inappropriate
[ __ ]
you know it's weird in south africa you
can't have a threesome with your parents
apparently that's weird everyone's like
whoa
what
grimes is sort of open and i feel like
my dad should have something
special before he leaves this earth
i wanted to do something that we could
share together
and so did she i would be cracking the
[ __ ] up
like this is this an incest joke or is
it not a joke is he talking about intest
[Laughter]
i think because all like his his version
of comedy is just
you know like making stuff 420
which i agree is funny yeah 420 is the
we all know that's the pot number and we
all know that's
[ __ ] funny yeah and same with 69
that's a great number too that's the
number that represents
yeah you know um when you're fellating
someone and then they're affiliating you
at the same time that's six
nine where it's a great number for
lading i like belating
yeah um inflate me
yeah he also did the he did the um
what was the tesla tequila that [ __ ]
sold out like right away
instantly gravy got one and wasn't it
420 bucks or something like that
yeah yeah i don't know 69 69 69 69
something
that bottle was dope though like do you
think you'd go on stage and just fart
and say my iphone passwords four four
two
zero six nine and then fart again
it could work look at my weed socks
wait dude did you you saw him tweet that
meme where it was like my lower back
hurts from carrying my massive [ __ ]
what yeah you don't care dude it's the
same sense of humor as like a
13 year old yeah he does not care
anymore it's kind of
it's kind of tight it's kind of dope so
maybe he's not a good
maybe i'm maybe i'm making this sound
too cool people are like what
elon might do open mics in austin that's
dope yeah so you know i'm i'm
i'm happy we stayed man i'm happy we
didn't do the uh
austin austin exodus
i i am too i mean i i like texas i'm
gonna go visit for sure
like no yeah i you know i'd like to go
to austin
like for sure next year for sure and
visit and see what it's all about but i
dude i just feel bad because we had an
uber driver
who was telling us how he grew up in uh
when we were there doing the austin show
by the way i had a crazy memory by the
austin show last night that i want to
play
but okay um and i remember
our uber driver he came from a flyover
state or
you know midwest east coast something
there and he
you know he moved to austin to change
his life because it was affordable
and the city he came from was [ __ ]
awful and he said man i love this city
because it just gave me so much
opportunity
because you know i can like rebuild my
life now and i just feel bad because i
guarantee there's definitely a certain
amount of people who move to austin for
that reason
and now these [ __ ] who have money in
california are going to be like
i don't want to pay taxes anymore and
then they just go over there and just
ruin that [ __ ] yeah just how
cost of housing skyrockets it's probably
going to explode man yeah and all these
people are
all these california people the barbecue
here is [ __ ] phenomenal
seriously it is phenomenal we do not get
barbecue like this in california
i swear to god meanwhile the [ __ ]
owner of the joint it's like
homeless now yeah bro i just picture a
bunch of people from silicon valley with
like
hair lines like in the middle of their
head and big-ass eyes and thin lips
being like i love the barbecue
the barbecue is so good seriously micro
dose a little tiny little shrooms
and then eat some of the barbecue and it
is life-changing dude it is
life-changing
[Laughter]
oh man the whole team would love this
barbecue we're trying a new thing
where we do adderall and mushrooms while
we work
and uh i don't really write much of the
code these days but
oh man they would love this you would
love
this soylent it's brisket flavored
seriously twice a day i drink this [ __ ]
and it's so good it tastes like mac and
cheese but the real
texas kind they're doing the they're
doing the thing or they're holding their
fork and knife while talking
yeah just pin down and just
every night i have a beyond burger have
you had a beyond burger
i'll tell you this is beyond this world
buddy oh my god
we're thinking about building one of
these barbecue joints
in the first floor of the office and so
what i did is i bought out this little
mom and pop shop and i fired them all
because they're
not efficient and we took the recipes
we plugged in some employees that i
actually shipped out from
san francisco real reliable folk and
and now we got barbecue in our office
wow this brisket's amazing i'm gonna buy
this place
[Laughter]
i got my buds on from kleiner perkins on
the phone right now they're willing to
invest for
four million dollars up front right now
if you
walk if you give this place to me give
me the keys right now we'll license your
name we'll sell a smoker and your name
will cut you in on three percent
[Laughter]
i'm gonna buy it it's no i like what i
do and
but we like it why not but this is i'm
doing feeling like
way more there's a little bit someone
could use this
thing i mean i appreciate that thank you
but yeah
oh it's how i support my family and i
just wanna
i wanna buy your family too
sure the barbecue tastes good but how
does millions of dollars
taste just give me your barbecue
restaurant and your family you can live
a life of luxury
[Laughter]
hey you're not a i'm certain i look like
[ __ ] through that whole bit because oh
man i should have shaved today
that would have made my face look a lot
less worse
a lot less worse less worse yeah that's
good
that's what being 30 is it's just trying
to look less worse yeah
it's just a really good way to put it um